a new wave of youtube entrepreneurs that
are generating
massive views and making a massive
difference and in this video
i'm actually going to be breaking down
the strategies
they are using to get views and
subscribers this year
i'm also going to be sharing a secret
that i learned from
gary vaynerchuk that he shared at
vaynermedia
and also the best channel ideas for
getting not just
views but making money this year
on youtube but i'm not sure if you've
seen yet
but the recent letter from the ceo of
youtube revealed some
startling data and it was this that
because of the pandemic
one of the trends that's happening on
youtube is people are learning
new skills um they discovered
that 77 of people uh 77
of respondents to an ipsco study said
that during 2020 they used youtube to
learn a new skill of course we've been
going through a global pandemic
people been stuck at home but it shifted
that the way the world operates
and people are utilizing youtube for
education content youtube
to learn a new skill youtube to discover
something and learn something they
haven't done before
in fact this is what it says it says
this trend has grown during the pandemic
as we've worked from home
schooled from home and adapted our lives
to quarantine in fact
videos with the word beginner in the
title have been viewed more than a
billion
times since march what's a video you
could do that's directed towards
beginners that maybe help somebody
that's starting something that you know
how to do last year
and this is the ceo saying i use youtube
to learn how to cut hair fix my fridge
do more yoga research bitcoin and help
with
physics homework and i would i'm curious
have you used youtube to learn anything
i mean you're maybe here
on this uh think video learning youtube
learning how to get views
but did you learn how to fix a
dishwasher did you start studying guitar
did you
do anything tell me in the comments down
below but here
this brings us to number one of three
strategies that we're going to be
talking about in this video
and the first one is this strategy if
you want to get
more views and really the little known
secret that top youtubers and this new
wave of youtube entrepreneurs are using
to get views the first thing is asq
answer
specific questions now you might say
sean
i think the people who get all the
massive views are the entertainment
channels right the
the people who get the massive views are
like mark uh robert like
uh mr beast you know channels like that
and sure
that's a massive movement on youtube the
music videos the justin biebers
but there's also videos like this and
you're gonna be shocked
like how to drill into your wall
right that's 1.3 million
views how about this how to approach a
girl works
every time strong that'll add on to the
title there
5.1 million views rv renovation on a
budget
step by step 510 000
views how to read the bible for
beginners seven tips you need to know
352 000 views so a question
is what's a specific question you could
answer
on your youtube channel again these
types of videos these education type of
videos
how-to types of videos not only were
always popular on youtube but the
pandemic
2020 has changed the way the world
learns
and the way the world seeks information
and 65
of people go to youtube trying to solve
a problem what's a specific
question what's something you could help
with and turning that into a video on
your channel look at this
five ways to make money on youtube with
a small channel this video over the last
three years
has gotten 2.1 million
views crazy right how about this how to
make a youtube video for beginners
start to finish and earlier we talked
about just using the word beginners in
your title
you can see 1.7 million
views and so i'm excited to get into the
next two tips but if you're new to the
show this is coffee with kannel my name
is sean
cannell rhymes with youtube channel and
we're going to be talking about the
little known secrets top youtubers use
to get massive views
and it's simply this right it's simply
the fact that they are
answering specific questions and there's
a couple other strategies that i want to
share with you in just a second
but if we're just meeting my passion is
to help you build your
influence with youtube it's not just
that i
teach about doing youtube but in
multiple niches i've grown different
channels
i have all kinds of different ranked
videos and like health and
christmas lights and all kinds of
different things i'm just obsessed with
youtube itself and it's changed my life
it helped me quit my job
and now it's my passion to help others
do the same in fact i'm most proud
of our students and you know these
examples of this new wave of
entrepreneurs
many of these uh people have started
from zero and gotten their silver play
button
um they're in niches like faith and food
and the keto diet and eye health and
parenting
and so i told you though and subscribe
if you are interested in
you know continuing to grow your youtube
channel but i told you i wanted to share
a cool secret that i learned from gary
vaynerchuk
about youtube success and i wrote a book
a while back
called youtube secrets and i wrote it
with my friend benji
and he actually went to vaynermedia and
talked to gary about um youtube
and if you've never heard of gary
vaynerchuk and you're in social media
have you been sleeping under a rock but
if you really have never heard about him
he's a multiple uh best-selling author
runs multiple businesses of about 1500
employees
and is a leading voice on social media
and so we were curious like
what's kind of your advice around
youtube and what's interesting
is this really reveals exactly what
we're talking about so let's watch this
and then i'm going to share with you
those two other tips
entertainment are you putting out
education because 90
of people are putting out selfish
content
and what was your question completely
starting from zero uh versus somebody
that has resources or team or already
started building an influence
you know it's kind of one and the same
like it's kind of like back to something
we talked about before which is like
making the best thing for the end
audience
i have synthesized my thoughts into
entertainment and education
that has become very clear to me that
either you're doing entertainment or
you're doing education and i actually do
think that
certain people like myself when you're
doing entertainment and education you
can really get crazy
um but that's what i would say i would
say to somebody with resources a four
person team
like look forget about everything else
because look i did
all i did all my content by myself for
seven years people forget they're like
oh easy for you to say i'm like
i'm like you're not you know it's that
iceberg yeah i'm like you see me i'm
like you know i'm like you see me now
i think it's about are you putting out
entertainment are you putting out
education
because 90 of people are putting out
selfish content yeah
90 of people are putting out press
releases they want to
they want you to think something about
them they're making it selfish for
themselves
they wanted to go to maui and serve
so that's the content you're getting but
did that bring you any value
they want you to think they're cool 90
of the content right now
are people acting like pr agents of
themselves
i'm asking people to look like educators
or entertainers
do you think about the audience first or
don't you
yeah so do you think about the audience
first or don't you and
are you putting out entertainment or
education and that's kind of the big
idea
is the little known secret of so many
top youtubers that maybe
you've never heard of before is they're
putting out education they're putting
out
service-based viewer helping
content and what's insane is that
because of us
working from home more learning from
home more online school
more is that these niches are blowing up
people searching for how to ride a bike
how to fix a bike and all types of
topics
like this which brings us to a youtube
secret and it's that the most
proven practical and profitable youtube
category
is education now don't mistake me
there's certainly
massive opportunity in entertainment and
if you want to be in entertainment more
power to you but we hit a question a lot
of times
people say sean how does my music
channel grow like for all of my music
and the
you know the singles i'm putting out and
the albums i want to put out and i'm
like i don't know you got to be really
good at music
i mean at the end of the day you've got
to be great at music
however when you step into education you
still got to know yourself
your stuff but you only need to be like
one or two steps ahead of people
you just need to help them learn
something you've learned you don't need
to have a degree
or be an expert you just need to help
someone learn
something that you've learned and if
you're literally one step in front of
someone else
you can help them achieve that same
result that
you achieved in your unique way with
your unique style
and so again the most proven and then
also
practical i believe the long tail of
opportunity for people going full time
on youtube
in the category of education is
unlimited
and the most profitable because people
want to learn so there's products
there's
online courses there's there's
skillshare there's brand deals there's
so many different things
around this and 70
of viewers use youtube to help them
solve
a problem so people are looking for this
information and so number one out of
three tips was asq answer specific
questions
and if you think about that think about
some of these questions that you could
answer
look at some of these stats views of
videos with variations of beginner in
the title increase more than
50 between march and july so people want
to learn stuff people want the education
but it goes deeper
globally these types of videos got 9
billion views last year what types of
videos
beauty tutorials increased fifty percent
bike maintenance
increased ninety percent raising
chickens
increased 160 percent learning guitar
saw 160 million views just from
mid-march to mid-april last year
container gardening saw six million
views in the same period
videos related to self-care saw 115
increase in daily uploads there was a
458
increase in the daily views of people
making sourdough bread
right like sourdough bread was blowing
up there was a 200
increase in the daily views of recipe
for recipe videos for bubble tea
how to do at home haircuts spiked
massively in april of course during the
lockdown so there is this
education revolution happening on
youtube
and this new wave of youtube
entrepreneurs that are
crushing it with this style of content
which brings us to the second strategy
for getting
massive use and it's rsp review specific
products
and smash like if you're getting value
out of this video so far so the first
one's answer specific questions the
second one is review
specific products have you ever seen
these massage guns before i'm a runner
and for recovery
i like to use these guns i use them for
you know kind of working at a desk so
i use them on my shoulders and my back
look at farragun vs hypervolt
massage gun 166 000 views another one of
the videos 266 000 views
how about this best christmas laser
lights
reviewing specific products 465
000 views and we talked about this being
the most profitable
style of videos as well this video has
earned over eight thousand dollars
directly
over the last couple years through
affiliate marketing and another six
thousand dollars
indirectly this video specific
products m50 versus the sony a6400 it
has a million views
one million views crazy right now we're
not going to go into all the
monetization strategies and if you want
to learn
uh some of those more monetization
strategies again we talked about the
most proven practical and
profitable category if you're curious
about how to
profit in multiple different ways from
videos like this i have a free class and
if you haven't seen it
thinkmasterclass.com link in the
description down below i'll i'll break
down
a lot of cool stuff as far as the best
ways to make money even if you have a
small audience
the mistakes people are making that's
why these videos aren't getting views
and the most recent tactics based on
youtube's newest update so that's at
thinkmasterclass.com if you want to
watch that for free
all the details are in the description
but that brings us to tip number three
and it's tss
teach specific skills
right people are trying to learn stuff
beginners are trying to learn
different types of skills you don't have
to have some crazy level of skills if
you're two steps ahead
you can help the person just starting
but teach specific skills
look at this this adobe premiere
tutorial that omar did on the think
media channel
is on its way to a million views right
the little known secret that top
youtubers are using to get massive use
that's a lot of views for something
that's super
practical right this is mary and you saw
her with the silver play button
how to make homemade apple cider vinegar
she's just passing along family recipes
passing along
her skills this is nicole from kidsot
help
tummy time for newborns 3.1
million views tss teaching
specific skills and when you think about
it
youtube's kind of like when the student
is ready the teacher appeal
appears because people go to youtube
with the intent of solving problems
and so if you're not a parent you'd
probably never need this video but once
you become one
all of a sudden your whole life like i
mean for me i recently became a dad
right and so
i'm uh sean bradley cannell is almost
seven months old now
as you can see things are going great
i've got everything under control right
and so as we look to youtube to learn
what are the best parenting books how do
you get him to enjoy
time he doesn't enjoy tummy time right
now maybe no baby does
that's the point of nicole's video right
teaching
specific skills that people need at
different seasons in their life
this is uh brett brent and uh he's from
bring your own tools
he's actually one of our video racket
academy students just got his silver
play button
stamped concrete right diy accent wall
but look at this
how to build a walnut dining table
1.9 million views absolutely insane
teaching specific skills and so
answer specific questions review
specific products and teach
specific skills and notice a really key
word did you see it
specific i think that's the power is
that sometimes we just shoot out videos
scatter shot
here's my ideas for the day as gary said
we just kind of create selfish content
like
here's what i want to do today here's
what
i want to talk about me this video is
about
me this whole channel is about me and
that's fine if that's working for you
but if it's not working for you maybe
consider flipping the perspective and
not making selfish content but making
service content
and solving people's problems answering
people's questions reviewing products
that people are interested in that
you've been testing out
so they don't have to so for shopping
from home they can get some good data
from you
who has the same body size as them who
can say
i'm 6'1 kind of lanky and this is how
the rhone workout shirt fits on me link
in the description down below
this was a little too tight i'd go with
xl instead of l
that's helping people answering specific
questions
reviewing specific products and then
teaching specific skills
and so tell me down below too in the
comments like what is a product you
could review in your niche or topic
or what's a skill you could teach even
if these
are just part of your video library i
want to encourage you
i believe these videos are going to get
you more views and they're actually you
might be surprised
that if you really lean into this style
of content this category and these types
of videos
you'll get some crazy results and again
if you want to go a little bit deeper
and learn
exactly how to position these videos
title them and so many other questions
just check out thinkmasterclass.com
and we really go deep into the different
ways of monetizing these styles of
videos as well so check those out in the
description
down below to get access to this
on-demand
class coffee with kennel
i'm here good to see you smash like and
thanks for being here we're going to
bring some guests on and we're gonna
answer
some questions today um and
uh we have uh gina coming on in just a
second
but i hope you're well uh today is water
with cannell because i got some water
with me in a mason jar
and uh i hope you're i hope you're doing
well if you've got a question throw up
uh four question marks before and after
your question
um so i can see that we'll answer a few
questions too as well as bring on some
guests
and uh if you haven't checked out that
web class before you can check that out
the free web class
as well that details are on the screen i
see so many great ideas you could review
different children's bibles that's
really strong
daily mom living i've done this and it
feels good to create service content i
love it awesome awesome so many great
ideas
can i start with a phone uh laura asks
absolutely
in fact we have a video that will show
you exactly heather taurus teaches
how to shoot with a phone iphone
how to do a thumbnail that's great with
your iphone edit with apps that are on
your phone
upload it all from your phone and so
we'll post a link to that
uh in the description as well as in the
live chat if you're here
live um and so uh if you got a question
go ahead and drop things down how does
this apply to a podcast
i mean directly our podcast which i hope
you're subscribed here on the think
marketing channel where this is
streaming um answer specific questions
um we answer questions recently last
couple episodes have been about
launching a book and lessons we've
launched in a book
um we also you don't necessarily as much
review products but you certainly could
we're going to be talking about
different
uh crms and like online course hosting
platforms let's talk about the
difference between kajabi and click
funnels and teachable and thinkific
so that episode ties directly into a
podcast at least for us
now i don't know what how your podcast
is angled but again your podcast if it
solves a problem if it's education
you could certainly talk about what are
your five best products in your niche if
you had an outdoor podcast
what are your you know five favorite
accessories you like taking when you go
on hikes
that's reviews teaching a specific skill
i'm going to teach you
it could be a mindset or a confidence
contest my friend john acuff
who's coming on the podcast soon has a
book called soundtracks and it's about
overcoming overthinking so he gives you
actually tools like
if you have a thought you need to ask
yourself three questions
if it's kind of a negative thought you
say is it true well it might be true
uh is it helpful it might not be helpful
but it might be
but also number three is it kind so
powerful insight that i learned from
john acuff but that could be delivered
in audio on a podcast
hey when you're you know overthinking
about things run it through this filter
and he just delivered a framework
so these styles of content could be very
helpful
uh for a podcast and i'm all i mean
there's
true crime podcasts and there's
entertainment podcasts and there's
reviews of
a lot of different things those niches
are great too i'm just suggesting that
based on this video
you definitely can apply these things
even in a podcast in the education niche
and with that
gina welcome to the show tell me about
your channel and
uh what your question is today hi sean
thank you so much for having me on as a
guest
i just want to let you know that your
book is the first one i read when i
started
this my channel is for nursing students
it's to help them with test anxiety and
it is a review
of nclex style questions so i'm a
nursing instructor
and it's basically how i would review
before tests with
my students and it's on each one
is a very short video on a very specific
nursing topic so if you know like for
example one would be
on copd one would be on
asthma you know so it's just that one um
topic my question to you is that
um i am not on the videos i don't appear
on the videos
um i do it all on software on camtasia
that and the last one i did was yep
that's my newest one
and my question is do i need to be on
camera
for this type of education
would it be better or would it be
distracting
so that's a great question and a
question i'm sure a lot of people have
let's
just check your channel out and then
i'll uh drop some things so
so one video published in the last month
uh
kind of just getting started i mean a
couple new subscribers 53 videos
uh views and videos have been coming out
so
so it's it's youtube it's your tube
even though we want to make service
content you can do it in whatever style
you want um you're very much answering
specific questions here
and for somebody who just wants this
information i'm sure they've been
incredibly grateful have you gotten
feedback from anybody that comes like
wow this is so thankful like uh
have you connected with some people yeah
i actually have
a facebook community group under the
same name and a facebook page and we
have about 89
people on the community group and so i
asked them for feedback all the time
and i've gotten a lot i started off
basically with the students from my
college that was my
original like niche and then it's grown
um from there and they said that it is
very helpful that they like the way it's
done they like that it's quick that they
could
listen to it in their car as they're
driving to school on their pods and
they just have that one thing if they
only want one specific thing from
cardiac
they can just listen to that video if
they want all of them they can listen to
the whole playlist
so none of them have mentioned that they
would like to see me on the video
um i just was wondering if what you
thought if you thought it would help or
if it wouldn't
yeah so amazing and a couple things to
break down i mean first of all
you answered your own question there and
i just also want to acknowledge you it's
such a great example of what we just
shared
like your students are grateful you're
answering
specific questions it's a resource
that's there for them
um they have not they're not complaining
in fact they love it there's 37 likes on
this video 2791 views
so success leaves clues not only that
this
video is working it's very helpful but
even this one continues to be watched so
you think about what other future topics
could maybe relate to this dimensional
analysis
or other parts related to that if it was
about ultimately getting more views but
i would summarize with a few tips
and that is a you're still pretty early
stage in this and you're building up
your facebook group which i love
and you're attracting a very specific
group of people
so one thing to remember when you are
making progress even if the initial
growth feels slow
just keep going because it's serving
people it's helping people you're
getting positive feedback
do more of what you're doing secondly
i want to encourage you to experiment if
you would want to if you don't want to
be on camera or it's like it's just
working and you like this rhythm once
you get into rhythm you might as well go
for it however we should always be
disrupting ourselves with
experimentation and i would even
challenge everybody watching
if you're always on camera try not being
on camera there's what's called
faceless channels try try to experiment
with different content formats
it would be like a musician who doesn't
play jazz
tries jazz even if they're not going to
continue to
learn it or or create jazz music because
it'll probably better
inform them rhythmically and musically
for the main genre that they typically
create music in
and so trying to make a more cinematic
video or trying to make
a voiceover video with b-roll from a
stock footage site or something for
everybody watching
that's just experimenting with different
content formats today omar released a
video
that you could do vlog videos talking
head videos faceless videos was one of
the examples you could do a live stream
so if you never switched up your formats
try that you could try a live q a like
this
and bring people on you could schedule
people ahead of time and say we're going
to be answering
doing conversations about your first
year in nursing
so thinking outside of the box that it's
it's your tube
it's youtube to experiment and what
happens when you spend some of your time
experimenting
is that's research and development
that's r d that's when
you go oh my gosh people love this show
where i do kind of like a coffee with
candle thing with something like stream
yard
and where i talk people through nursing
and they just love how rich those
conversations are
and that could lead to something else or
you try being on camera for a while
um with a couple videos and you go
didn't really get different results the
results were worse or the same or
i didn't enjoy doing it so don't be
afraid to
experiment and my final thought is again
i think what you're doing is working
um and i think that some of the other
things you could do
is i would like to see maybe a little
bit of a pivot to the thumbnails
because they're pretty they're pretty
busy
and one of the things i recommend is you
don't need to echo the title
in the thumbnail okay so what i mean is
acute respiratory distress syndrome
and it says acute respiratory distress
syndrome
so the goal would not be unlike today's
coffee with panel notice there's no
words just a question mark
and really trying to go for you know the
little known secret top youtubers
so hopefully this grabs attention and
then what do you do next is you read
what's on the right this past one a
couple stats from the book and obviously
words on the book cover
but i'm trying to do as few words as
possible
and those words are not echoing the
title they're maybe reinforcing
or reaching out to grab the viewer's
attention
so you could definitely utilize some
kind of stock photography site as you've
been doing
in relation to things that would attract
uh the nursing community that they'd
maybe want to click on
but consider not just use using any
words or just using
like things that they would want is
maybe
easy ways to pass the test like such as
that's title about accomplishing a
nursing test and it's like
test made easy like think about a
headline like super simple
and my favorite uh trick for this is
every time you go to the grocery store
start looking at the magazines and the
uh
tabloid headlines and little call
outs because on the headlines and the
little call outs
they only have a few uh
tiny sentences to contain a lot of
information
and so it'll get you thinking while
you're in while you're sitting at the
grocery store instead of being on your
phone
you could start looking at the cover of
magazines to think about how to quickly
communicate information and so i think
about
the man with 106 babies
you know like oh my gosh 239 style tips
your for your work wardrobe you know and
and it'll help you think like you know
that these types of whatever magazine uh
they have very few words who do we vote
for now
whatever and it just is that the music
that matters
our 2015 hall of fame portfolio
how to crank up your style so maybe if
if the title for somebody watching in
like
the style niche was best spring
fashion ideas from the thrift store
and then the the thumbnail says how to
crank up your style you know with a
picture
so it's not echoing the title it's
complementing the title
if you um do put words in the thumbnail
is that helpful yeah very helpful thank
you
awesome well i appreciate you thanks so
much for coming on the show
all right thank you all right take care
coffee with kennel crew have you are you
gonna do that next time you're at the
grocery store
are you back at the grocery store are
you still staying home
and avoiding going out uh
sausage has a great question i want to
hear your opinion on shorts
and is that something to get into now um
i i love youtube shorts um we're
three or four in on think media now our
goal is to do two
a week on think media um our goal in the
future
is to probably start a clips channel
which would not be exclusively shorts
um i think that whenever a new feature
comes out
it's uh it's good to use it and
experiment with it
and so if you haven't checked out our
other channel we're here on our think
marketing channel
um check out think media we have a new
short out today and you can get kind of
a vibe
for it um i think if you haven't updated
your youtube app
um and you're watching this update your
youtube app and you might have a shorts
creator
right there on the app itself which is
similar to instagram reels you can
actually integrate popular music
uh combine multiple clips and editing
together
and there it's gonna be 60 seconds it's
going to be vertical and you could
create that on your iphone or your
android
i'll just give it a call back uh sasha j
to
the experimentation idea um i think
that when you have the bandwidth when
you have a
the you know a little bit of uh time or
just the
uh take some put a little calendar block
on your calendar
to experiment with shorts create a short
post one um it may not end up being
something you do heavily on your main
channel
and so i'll report back to you with more
data our goal is to get
over 10 posted study them all and we'll
always report to you on the findings so
that's a good reason to always stay
subscribed to the think channels because
we like to be player coaches
we like to do the experiments be in the
trenches see what we can learn
we want to try different shorts formats
if that makes sense
you know uh kind of education-based ones
maybe entertainment-based ones where we
just show off a compilation of the
footage or photography from a camera
and then maybe use it to link to a full
video about the review
or details about that camera so the
30 000 foot headline though is if you've
got the bandwidth
um absolutely experiment but if
you're also we have not dove like super
headfirst
into them because our main strategy is
working great
it's enough you know we have multiple
content creators but to create five
videos
a week and to sustain that and their
quality tutorials and reviews and so on
and so forth so we are it was a
bandwidth question
man even though they're quick to make
our our rhythm and the library we're
building and the whole strategy of asq
and answer specific questions and the
stuff we teach in the master class
like that's crushing for us so i'll land
the plane saying
if it ain't broke don't fix it
but at the same time you always want to
be putting yourself out of business and
what i mean is
you always want to be saying what am i
not seeing that could be the next thing
so i like to spend 20 or 10 percent of
my time
experimenting on the next thing dabbling
on the next thing i feel guilty
let me give you one other tip we haven't
started tick tock yet i guess i do have
a tick tock but we'll probably start a
think media one
and so we're gonna probably eventually
have
shorts as maybe the w where you think of
shorts first
and then some of those we'll use on
instagram reels and some of those will
also use on tick tock
because vertical content is vertical
content
that's maybe a little oversimplified
because sometimes the music native which
platform is the best so we're gonna have
an intentional strategy not just
repeating everything everywhere
but once we make something thoughtfully
we might distribute it multiple places
to leverage tick tock
and i i should be on tick tock but i'm
also
i don't know i'm a dad i got a seven
month old
um our team's busy we're getting there
but one thing at a time so don't beat
yourself up if you feel like you don't
have time to do it all
we try to be smart we try to do what
we're doing well and then think about
how we can scale into doing what we need
to do next
so with that i'm excited because we have
a couple guests
coming on we're gonna have uh brian uh
on
in just a second and we're gonna have
kristin uh cryptic jasmine
and on in a second but we have uh nada
up first hey nada where are you from and
what's your channel about
hey my channel is about style for
women over 40.
awesome and did you post it in the
private chat or can i
um what's it called
it's called neta manly style
awesome so what's your question today so
i have been
doing research keyword research i use
tubebuddy i'm a little frustrated with
it right now frankly because
one of the features on tubebuddy lately
has not been working
um and it's the the keyword explorer
feature
when you that lets you import a bunch of
keywords
sure so it hasn't been working properly
and
um so i've been having to do the keyword
research myself anyway when i
when i do keyword research i'll get like
a
a 100 score on
um one of the videos and that's not a
video that ends up doing that well
sure so i'm just kind of confused like i
i just
researched a couple of videos i was just
working on a couple of new ones like
four ways to make any outfit more
interesting
so i got a hundred score on
that topic but then i go in and
hey someone said hi um i go in and i
um do a video about that and i
optimize it the best way that i can i
loved your tip about making the
thumbnail
copy different that was so good um
because i'm
you know always working on that but yeah
i just wonder why those aren't always
the videos that rank really well
and if there's something that you're
seeing that i can do that might
change my trajectory of my channel right
now it's kind of like
slowly growing at about 100 people a
month i would say
um i started it about a year ago almost
exactly a year ago
and i just wanted to grow faster i love
it well
yeah let's dive in so um you know i
uh keyword research
is so critical it's really i consider it
topic research
but there's also other ways to do topic
research um i'm a huge vidiq fan
and so if i think about i'm gonna go
actually back to
um like this video just to use it as a
jump off point
one tip always success leaves clues and
it's been a year since you've made
things related to body type so it might
be good to circle back
we always like to kind of remake and
update our winners if we go to keyword
inspector here
though in vid iq um
kind of talk about a couple things i go
by search volume
and i i will be even on vid iq
or tubebuddy i'm honest honestly i don't
worry too much about
the scores it's a tool lets you know
what the competition is
um but also some of these things these
are very vague these are a little too
short
how to dress for your body type so
that's medium
there's some decent search volume 45 out
of 100
but where i it would really get
interesting for me
is one of my favorite research to do is
actually on youtube itself
so i'm going to take that keyword that i
just learned in vid iq
i'm going to go to how to dress for your
body type and now i'm going to kind of
look at the top videos and i'm going to
study their thumbnails their titles the
video length
and think about okay what could how
could i jump inside of this conversation
i also would probably use that
foundationally and now you can see
so notice i started very with powerfully
with the tool
like vidiq and then i found
something that interest me got that tip
two right
then i took that out of the tool now i'm
taking it to
youtube and i'm looking at some of these
details
like maybe i want to make this video
because i want to go even longer than
this this is quite a bit of competition
some bigger channels or bigger subscribe
channels
but now i'm interested maybe in even
specific size like
apple right so that's a body type
hourglass that's a body type
to show your best assets but even even
maybe a quiz
and this that might give me maybe you
could create a quiz that could help you
build an email list these are ideas that
just come to me as i'm kind of
you know but maybe you ultimately go
female but but you said what was
uh females of a certain age
sorry it's for women over 40. so
so uh how to dress your body type
i might end up doing like uh you know
over 40 in the title and
and then try to really rank obviously
there's a man with the same kind of
title
really a lot of views on there uh
and as i'm doing this now i'm also
checking out
and this is sort of the combination i
hope this comes across
keyword research and topic research is
sort of
where i like to begin to start
generating ideas but i might
spin off because youtube's also very
much about trending
topics and it isn't necessarily in 2021
about just exact keyword match so like
the new style
rules over 40 is just a great title and
i'm like huh
can i do like a version of that could i
spin off something on that if that video
is doing well
so my topic research is kind of being
influenced by
what's performing well on youtube itself
what could i learn
maybe from that creator and and then i
also
oftentimes will just use the youtube
search bar so like women
over 40 and the workout will go
underscore before
uh let's see or i'll go over 40
uh fashion uh and then we'll go
you know okay kind of see what that is
i'm gonna go under skype plus size
fashion what to wear
fashion over 40 petite women's fashion
over 40.
so then you know this is sort of you're
you're going through
exact hey great job really great job so
that's that's like a great example
of uh of of finding like a smart idea
hitting it very specific
in fact what we taught today answer
specific questions is a very specific
best petite brand so i love that
but do you see is that helpful at all
it's kind of like
i guess what i'm trying to say is use
the tools but
also use your intuition and do more
study
of youtube itself to maybe find video
ideas that
don't maybe fit nicely inside of the
keyword tools
and when you are using keyword tools
don't be afraid of
don't even put too much stake in the
score i mean
even this i just use this as a reference
point that petite women's fashion let's
say
that iq in this case on the right side
is telling me
it's a 31 out of 100 i'm gonna look at
that and be like okay
but then i'm gonna look at maybe some of
the channels i could study
i'm going to scroll down definitely i'm
going to look at the trending videos
in terms of like okay black blazer
spring outfla it maybe i say
little liney thing women over 40. i look
at
the trending videos because you want
your videos to be suggested alongside of
these and youtube
really works related to trends and
specific niches niches
secrets to wearing youthful fashion over
40 with confidence like even that is
like
that's not a search term
but it's doing well so then i i dig into
that video and i think okay
what can i learn about this particular
video
um and traffic the number one traffic
source on youtube
is recommended videos not search
i believe that search is the
foundational place to start and even
reach into recommended videos
when you strategically knit the whole
strategy together
um so the keyword research matters but
then it see how it took us to this place
of
trending videos and then we synthesize
that
in terms of what are you inspired by
right now what do some of these in
videos
inspire inspire you to think about
and off the final thing i'll say is
remember suggested videos are so
powerful on youtube
and a lot of people will watch more than
one video on a very specific topic
in my case if somebody releases a new
uh video about the sony a1 camera
i'm like i watch three four videos about
it to get different perspe i want to
watch
test photos i want to watch the 4k
example footage
i watch a review from someone i trust
somebody catches me with the headline
and suggested videos about
why you shouldn't buy the new sony a1 i
got to click that too
so when someone is looking for secrets
to wearing youthful fashion
and a video and maybe a much larger
channel is doing well
when you make related videos
your chance of showing up and suggested
is is pretty high
maybe someone looks at that individual
and says i don't really look like them
and my body type's not the same as them
but they see you in the thumbnail and
they go
oh she looks nice like maybe let me give
her a try see how that could work let me
give her a try they click on that
and you're getting new audience because
your bible attracts your tribe
in not every especially in fashion
different body types different styles
different size
so someone might be super famous but
there's a trickle from their
influence that could lead to you as you
just are bold
with your best features your uniqueness
right they're like oh cool like i it
looks like i can maybe relate and you
even think about how that's in the title
and
none of that might be keyword-based it's
more
human-based and it could really lead to
your videos so was that making some
sense
yes that that is thank you thank you
yeah the keyword research was was kind
of confusing to me i don't i
am not ranking for any words yet and i'm
so specific
so i'm just like it's style over you
know for women over 40. i'm not the only
one in the space of course but
i was just perplexed like why am i not i
don't think i'm showing up in search and
suggested
i don't think i'm ranking for any
keywords at least not that i can tell
um i bet you are i'm going to show you
how to look
so um what you want to do is
i'm sure you are for any different so
here's here's a quick analytics crash
course
on traffic sources so just look at your
last month in the last 28 days
and it'll actually if it says youtube
search you are showing up in search if
it says suggested videos
you are showing up in suggested videos
and so i promise you
you're showing up in both because you
are getting views to be even more
specific
uh this is a huge mistake people make
when it comes to ranking
is they think um let me go to maybe a
very search-based video like youtube
versus instagram
see the mistake people make is they'll
use vid iq
they'll put some tags on a video they
won't see any blue ranking numbers
although this one is ranking number one
for instagram versus youtube so that's
that's kind of the ultimate goal but
let's say you didn't see that
the question is though are you even
using the right tags are you cause if if
they weren't there it actually doesn't
mean that the video wouldn't rank
um the the way to actually test things
is to go into the reach of the specific
video
and come down here to youtube traffic
source youtube search
and verifiably it will tell you even if
it quote unquote doesn't rank
right now it'll say that people typing
youtube versus instagram has gotten this
15 views
people typing instagram versus youtube
has got in this video nine views
um some people search think media or
sean cannell so that's a little bit
different
and then some people searching for all
kinds of other stuff
this video popped up like how to grow on
social media this video got a view
it doesn't rank for how to grow on
social media but
it did at that moment if that makes
sense
so definitely i think you're probably
being too hard on yourself in terms of
thinking you're not
getting traffic um because i'm i promise
you you are
you could check out where it's coming
from in your analytics
okay is that helpful yes very helpful
thank you so much hey i appreciate you
so much and thanks for coming on the
show
i appreciate it thanks have a good one
my friends smash like if you've been
getting value have you had an aha moment
yet
um in this video and uh
we see makes a ton of sense um i hope
that was helpful you could check your
analytics
channel wide here's how your your your
youtube channel works
when you go into analytics and you click
analytics this is analytics for the
entire channel
starts over the last 28 days this is
your
traffic over your entire channel over
the last 28 days
so on think media we get 40 percent
traffic
uh from youtube search 17
from suggested browse features is also
videos showing up on the home page
as well as the subscription feed 15 10
from external
but notice you could also switch to
lifetime and that'll probably change
youtube search stays pretty consistent
but drops to 39
but remember you can now do this for
specific videos so if you're ever
judgmental of a specific video go
actually look at the real data so let me
look at a video that's a little bit
older
and we'll also look earlier we
recommended how to make
a video on your phone this is the video
how to make a youtube video
just on your phone and heather teaches
this so
when we look in here this video has had
a lot of life to it almost 2 million
views
and in this case youtube search was not
the biggest traffic source 10
this is a great example 67.2
of the views on this video have been
from this video being suggested
views from suggestions appearing
alongside or after
other videos so
to break down kind of what you'll learn
as you go deeper with think
we still think that search based content
doing topic research and keyword
research and answering specific
questions is where you should start on
youtube
it's even how you should continue on
youtube once you get some momentum
you got to tap into suggested traffic
you got to tap into trends
you got to tap into very clickable
titles and it becomes
kind of understanding both is where real
youtube mastery
uh can happen to where and it depends on
your
niche as well to be clear based on the
title the little known secret
of top youtubers we're talking education
channels is where there's massive
opportunity you know a lot of people
they're not searching for um
certain entertainment based content that
content is coming to them via
recommendations
as an educator as someone who's
answering specific questions reviewing
specific products
and teaching specific skills you really
want to tap into a tool like vidiq so
you can
make data driven decisions follow trends
and make related trending videos
and if you haven't we by the way
you can always try out vid iqs some of
their advanced features vidiq.com
forward slash think
if you have any questions about that
kind of stuff i told that we have uh
i said brian's on next so we got brian
brian where are you from and what's your
channel about
you're muted let me unmute you uh you
can only unmute yourself okay i'm here
sorry about that my man go for it hey
i'm in uh well
closest city is panama city beach about
hour away from there
in florida by the way man to man dad to
dad
congratulations on the baby i've been
following you guys for quite some time
and that's
it's a new life isn't it yes it is i
appreciate that thank you
um yeah uh so the channel is about
aviation
it's very niche there um so my keywords
is like aircraft airplane pilot
that's it over and over and over again
okay what's the channel called
experimental aircraft channel okay yep
um so i basically cover experimental
light sport and ultralight aviation
i will go to manufacturers and do kind
of like a howitz made
factory tour to show people you know
what that looks like
i'll interview people that are building
aircraft at their home hangar kitchen
counter sometimes
and do videos like that and it's it's
working well i've went to zero to 67 000
subscribers in two years and i want to
say thanks to you and
your crew i've watched probably half of
the videos because you've got like
thousands of them out there
to get to where we are now we went full
time last year awesome
awesome that all being said um everybody
who's listening watching
you can stick with sean because him and
his crew really have some
deep deep meaningful content for you to
watch
um that'll be inside i have a few
questions for you um
one i thought i understood you know the
whole monetization thing and all that
and maybe i do but recently i've noticed
like just the last few months even
i'm just curious of how in your mind
decide this works because
um the uh the payout from adsense has
gone down
almost to the dollar like a thousand a
thousand
a thousand so i'm just curious like in
this space especially because such a
niche
market if they literally just like all
right this is how much pie we have
and we're gonna divide it up between all
these aviation channels and whatever is
there is there
or is it really more towards like the
algorithms of
the search because it seems like i mean
sean almost to the dollar
the last two months it's gone down by
one thousand and then almost a thousand
again
how much how much you're earning has
gone down by about a thousand a month
correct gotcha have you been tracking
your revenue
uh cpms and rpms yeah that's gone up a
little bit maybe a dollar
dollar and a half two dollars because
because at the end of the day
let's break it down okay so showing
think media
um you can see over let's say the last
uh lifetime that was a little long
that's probably too long
let's see let's go to last year um you
could see that
our playback cpm on
average over the last year
has been 18 you can see that
you can track literally what it is
historically over the last year we hit
spikes of 25
and lows of 15. now for those watching
cpm is costs
per ml which means cost per a thousand
so you make 18 dollars per thousand
monetized
views um and that's another thing to
consider
if for some reason your audience had
increased usage of ad blockers
um or just ads they're not being served
to them for some reason
um that's the the ad has to be actually
served and
seen now that's not how much money you
make though the rpm is how much money
you make
and if you don't get a lot of super
chats from going live
because what youtube does is they
combine all of your revenue together
which i think is kind of cool but i
think it's a little sketch because it
look it's memberships
super chat super stickers which
convolutes the number
i'm actually glad that we don't do too
much of that although if you want to
drop a super chat on this video because
you're getting value i would appreciate
it
um but so so this number is pretty
accurate based on just ad revenue
you know what that tells me is it shows
which we have no quoted percentage
but it shows that i'm only keeping over
the last year
around eight dollars and youtube's
keeping 10.
so um that's kind of how that works cpm
versus rpm
and again it's a little tough to figure
that out you could calculate it other
ways
as far as your estimated monthly revenue
etc
so if you tell me man every month it's
going down
but your cpm is going up and your rpm
or whatever if it's staying mostly the
same then it's also are you getting the
same
amount of views then you have to say am
i getting the same
amount of ad ad plays um
as well and so um there's views versus
you know how many views were actually
monetized is all
is kind of the question and then there's
ways to
kind of clap back uh to
to the system and that is considering
doing like multiple ad spots
so on a video like this and monetization
um we have before the video during the
video after the video
overlay skippable and non-skippable i do
not do sponsored cards
and and we just let youtube determine it
but you see there's actually three
ad spots going to play in the middle of
this video which
is if youtube ad revenue is one of the
things you want to increase
that's going to be really helpful this
is a longer free
educational video i'm sure someone could
go yeah
why are you showing me an ad to which
i'd say dude
i just made a 44 minute strategy
free video why don't you pay for youtube
red dude you pay for netflix why aren't
you supporting your local creator
so if you notice i'm sure you have
because you look at all these analytics
i do i i stick to a rule of tried to do
20 minutes or less right because it just
becomes too long people don't click on
it
so 18 19 minutes is my average but i do
sometimes 12 minutes if you see a 12
minute video
that youtube automatically populates you
might get three
inserts right 20 it could be five to
eight
it's like youtube do you want people to
click off of my video because you put on
eight vid you know
eight ads i haven't really seen that
maybe that's what you see but notice i
i did not manually set those that was a
40 minute video and it only did three
so by the way you could go in and just
had one you could add it at a strategic
place
um you know those those things are up to
you but that would be a way to to lift
it
and and so then you you put all these
factors together what's your cpm what's
your rpm how many views are you getting
how many ads are actually playing
because one view
could be multiple ads being served any
feedback on that i mean this might be
information you've known
so does that adjust what you think might
be happening
um possibly the other thing i want to
consider share with you here
i mean let's back all the way out for a
second here and how this works we all
get paid because
people are buying ads and putting ads
from our videos right
and maybe for and correct me if i'm
wrong this is such a super niche market
of
not just aviation but experimental
aviation right the piece of the pie is
smaller
so the people that are buying ad space
is gonna be less than the
like an automotive channel and maybe
there is only so much
monetization coming from that niche to
put in from my channel so if if they
have another big
air show to go to and they're spending
ten thousand dollars on a booth
maybe the last couple months there just
isn't they're not spending the money
would that make sense to uh the line of
thinking makes sense but i don't think
that's what's happening because
okay because i'm actually sure your
audience uh maybe is a little bit older
you know 35 to 55 or old you know
and therefore they have a little bit
more money
if this is a hobby they almost for sure
have money or they
aspire to to do it someday therefore a
lot of what cpm is based in ad placement
is based
on the demographic no matter what they
watch so if the video is monetized
uh movies could be showing up movie ads
you know
really broad at squarespace.com type of
things
so if you're yeah i wouldn't even
think um there might i don't even think
actually
companies that would want to reach your
audience are that smart
like maybe five percent of them would
think
i should go because they can they could
go manually select your videos and put
the right products on your videos
you're talking i mean you're you're deep
in this you're deep in social media
you're deep in that thinking
the world is a lot further behind like
anybody watching this
like if you're like you feel like you're
too late no you're in a super niche
subculture
that's aware of cpms and rpms so to to
to that end that would be a brilliant
strategy
and someone should pay a more premium
cpm
if they're in the industry that would be
reaching the perfect customer of
watching your videos
but i would just think chances are
there'd be the broad uh
and what is your cpm like do you know
what it is off the top of your head i
want to say somewhere
seven fifty eight fifty yeah so that's
uh
you know average is like two to five so
that's already a little bit it's you
know it's
edging up therefore you know people that
just want to reach
a certain demo a certain intent are
going to be playing ads so i would think
unlimited ads would play on your videos
maybe people bidding lower because of
how the system works
uh could drive that down a little bit
and it's all the marketplace right that
youtube is
always navigating but yeah i mean my
thought is
i i would have with what you're doing
first of all
legit you know quarter million views a
month 1300 new subscribers you're
posting nine videos a month
things are going great you've got a good
momentum i'm sure you've got a ton of
super fans
the level of how you could monetize all
of this i mean you're already full time
but i believe there's just unlimited
scale
in terms of monetizing in other ways i'm
definitely thinking about creating your
own products or your own membership or
your own thing for exclusive content of
course that's one way
and we haven't even touched affiliates
yet so i mean
i know i'm sorry the full stack of all
the different things
but also specifically the the macro idea
is also going direct to the brand
um you're bypassing youtube adsense and
it might take
it might take 12 months that's the
entrepreneur hustle of going to the air
shows going to the things
but with the numbers you already have
and with how die
hard how focused this audience is
you are just in a unique position to
have a lot of influence
this is interesting about think media is
a good example some of the brands deals
we're doing
this might sound might be misinterpreted
we're not
that big of a channel in the grand
scheme of things we're not
a even the way we answer very specific
questions
a lot of videos get about 10 000 views
sometimes we hit 100 thousand and then
occasionally
we hit five hundred thousand to a
million so it's kind of a long tail so
it's
not like a famous uh quote unquote
youtuber again that gets five hundred
thousand a million two million every
upload
so you would also think we couldn't
command
higher dollars because of the views no
that's not
that's not the thing the focus of the
audience
the intent qualified customers qualified
because they're actually no i'm at think
media because i actually
want to purchase some lights or figure
out what camera to buy
therefore the brand deals we're doing
are crazy that don't map to
a tick tock influencer or just a you
know a comedy channel that
gets our same numbers so i would think
that that's the same thing the type of
audience you're reaching gives you a
very unique uh opportunity of going
direct to brands
um and starting to tap into all the
different monetization
strategies kind of that we teach uh on
exit can i ask you just one last
really big question important for
everybody here you've seen in the news
as well as everybody else that uh big
tech is in the spotlight right now
google owns youtube and that kind of
stuff um have you considered
for you personally and your team maybe
to just diversify a little bit aside
from youtube
in the event that big tech goes too much
under the microscope and maybe
is even taken down or split up 100
i uh there's the famous book by
the i think founder or one of the ceos
of intel
called only the paranoid survive
and so uh i'm a man of faith i live with
peace like a river
um and and and live in a state
i hope of different levels of anxiety
day to day
but as an entrepreneur paranoia is a
superpower
so it's the tension between paranoia and
peace it's like things are fine
i'm okay i live life with an open hand
in term of
of money or my business or even this
life like this life's a vapor
at the same time as an entrepreneur i
got my eyes wide open man i'm always
thinking about like who's trying to take
us out
what's coming next what if youtube
disappeared
tomorrow what if our amazon affiliate
account got shut down
that's why we have 21 different income
streams a video is coming out about it
actually breaking them all down
and that's it's diversif it's
diversification
that's why we have an email list and so
we would take
an insane blow if like our youtube
channel got deleted that's why we got
two
you know we've got there's a there's a
uh you might even know this in the navy
i learned this phrase i wasn't in the
navy but uh
from those in the navy that when you're
out to see
if it came to having a backup
transmission or a backup engine part
they would always say if you have one
you have zero
if you have two you have one because
if the transmission blows and you only
have one transmission now you're out to
see and you have no backup so what
happens if they both blow in a row
so if you got three you got two so we
have adopted that at think media we
always say that like
it it is in term of eventually if you're
building a team
that's why you want someone on the bench
it's just if there's no one on the bench
and someone gets taken out
maybe they get sick maybe they get
covered you know
they're if they're out for a couple
months maybe they get pregnant the
paternity leave this is the kind of
stuff i think about as an entrepreneur
so to your point um i lean heavy in with
always uh having optimism about my
day-to-day
but it's not delusion i got one eye open
when i'm sleeping
only the paranoid survive of like okay
what could happen next this is why we
build instagram
this is why we're hiring social media
people work with
think.com um and we're hiring different
team members
because we want to dominate all the
social platforms uh
and the only way to really do that
effectively and still spend really
quality time with your family
is by scaling up your team this is why
we have multiple revenue streams
so and answer your question absolutely i
actually don't really
fear it but i'm always preparing for it
and i think there's something powerful
in that preparation there's something
about joseph
saving up grain for seven years because
of seven years of famine i'm always
expecting
there to be a famine tomorrow while
being optimistic that there will be no
famine in the future
history has told us that there will
always be a famine
and now i'm kind of ranting but i i
actually am stunned
that so many people live paycheck to
paycheck
when they don't have to and they spend
their money on dumb things
when they just think that things today
they're they're living today only for
today and they're not preparing for
tomorrow
the way we run our our finances and our
economics at think
is by wanting to have healthy
uh cash flow and saved up cash it's not
a good investment
my cash in the bank for the business
right now
is hemorrhaging money i mean inflation
right
like the in in my my savings percentage
in my
savings account is point zero zero zero
zero
so it can't even keep up with inflation
i'm sure there's things you could do to
hedge against that
but having that cash is that buffer
that should something happen should all
the sudden we have a very expensive
thing come our way
we have the cash so we don't have to
slow down in business so i kind of took
that on a rant but
and that's what i'm looking at like you
know youtube is basically distribution
right i mean you're making
good content and it's a need for it but
youtube is distribution like where else
to dis
distribute to if youtube goes under
would you
you wouldn't do full-length stuff on
instagram you wouldn't do stuff facebook
has got some monetization
of course anyway i'm just that's what
i'm saying like where else to distribute
through other than youtube oh there's a
ton of options
and i mean at the end of the day
attention is attention
it could be facebook watch because face
it yes facebook videos but facebook
watch is a thing and there is some
monetization there
ig tv um is kind of
in a sort of a lull but it's still a
thing um
10 minute video length on linkedin
probably not the spot
but if it's not youtube it's going to be
shmutube like
shmutube like it'll it'll be the it
could be amazon prime did you know you
can upload to amazon prime
and there's you jump through a couple
hoops and um
there's some technical things to it but
it's just another distribution
channel um as well and so
there will always be
the next best thing they'll always be
the next best thing but they'll always
be consumers
that want good content about things
they're passionate about
and you are in a very great niche you
there's it's a subculture
it's a real community seth godin tribes
so
hear me i'm putting i'm betting maybe
i'm not betting ever
i'm betting every all the money that
people know about i
always my 80 i'm all in on youtube so
i'm like just
youtube and not like even we asked about
youtube shorts on like
youtube native content boom all in
but when i go all in it's never i always
got the backup right i was
i could always dig up the cash in the
backyard you know what i mean i was not
the extra bank account
so there's always the other 20 and i
think that's the best strategy
i would i would if i'm you next decade i
see youtube
going nowhere it not being disrupted at
all
i see the like it being broken up
probably not maybe so it's like we're
aware of that so i am all
in on youtube but i'm always
preparing and and making sure i've got a
lifeline
or other opportunities and whether in
all the areas we suggested
financial reserves diversification of
your audience building an email list
building a text message list we use
community you know
just different ways to communicate with
people in case
something was to get shut down we would
be devastated if our youtube channel got
deleted but we wouldn't be
dead follow me follow me from our great
ideas
yeah whatever whatever platform that's
on yeah yeah
so anyways that's just a few thoughts
that helpful perfect perfect
so much wisdom here people from sean my
man brian i appreciate you
appreciate you thanks for coming on so
coffee with keno smash
like button man we got on a rant there
but uh
you always got to be preparing for
tomorrow prior planning prevents poor
performance
if you fail to plan you plan to fail
prepare today and plant the seeds today
for the harvest you want to reap
tomorrow
and i'm all in on youtube but i always
am thinking about what's next i'm always
thinking about what could take us out
i'm always thinking about i think you
have to that's
my job it actually is not only is it my
job and your job as a solo creator but
it's more my job today as a ceo as a
business leader
with people depending on me to
live as garyvee says in the clouds and
the dirt the dirt is in the trenches
creating content being here with you on
coffee with candle the clouds
is the 30 000 foot level that's like
what's next what's happening what are we
doing strategically
are we prepared for the next thing um
how are
revenues how's the p l how's profit and
loss how are things going
and trying to make strategic decisions
at that level uh the dj tony areola
is on the back knowing that uh i'm now
late for our meeting
uh but i did say that cryptic jasmine
was coming on the show
and so we gotta have her on and uh
hey how's it going um where are you from
and what's your channel
hey sean i'm from san diego and i'm a
huge fan
and i just have to say thank you for all
of the value you provide but also for
all of the humor because you make me
laugh all the time
and uh ivan back here is cracking up too
but um i'm from san diego and my channel
is kind of a style channel um oh my dog
wants to say hi to
it's a gotham alternative style channel
and i know you're late so
i'll make it quick um basically i i have
a 40 hour job
that's kind of soul sucking but you know
you got to do what you got to do to pay
the bills
but eventually i would love to do
something full-time
um more in this kind of creative field
be a full-time youtuber absolutely would
love it but also like
i have a couple interviews on my channel
um just anything more in the creative
space
so i guess my main question is i am
doing some experimenting i started my
channel in
october of last year i have about 220
subscribers right now
oh my gosh please disregard that that
one
it's all just for style um but
i guess my main question is do you think
that as i'm experimenting with different
things and how i can really offer value
to like the goth and alt communities
is my style enough of an umbrella niche
to experiment with other things like i
have a couple space hey tutorials on
there
um as you said like trying on clothing
while i'm trying to kind of figure out
the my niche within the niche or niches
in the niche
um do you think though that like just
having an umbrella niche for now is
enough
to figure out how i can best offer value
to that community
100 and here's why thanks so much for
coming on
um you're in a unique spot that i think
some people could relate to
and one of the powerful things that
people misunderstand
is they think they think the niche
is trying on clothes and a lot of times
the niche isn't the even the style of
video you do they think the niche
is a cooking video a lot of times the
niche or the niche
is actually the audience that you're
talking to
and so the power of this channel is this
is a real movement you know that right
it's a real community it's a real niche
community it's a real subculture
it's a real group of people that will
relate
identify see you in the thumbnail see
the color schemes
see the vibes see the tiles titles see
the keywords
and click on those potentially so that's
a very powerful thing and for those
maybe new to that idea
make sure you read seth godin tribes
it's can you're talking to
a pre-existing tribe you did not create
the goth niche right
uh but you're a part of that community
alt community and you're creating
content in it
therefore exactly what you said too
because you're at early stage in your
channel congrats almost 8 000 views
posting videos you've built out the
momentum of even being able to create
videos
i think literally i would i would take
time
well i'd make a list but then i would
take time experimenting with whichever
one of these
video ideas resonate with you so you
could
keep doing the halls um i would tap into
reacts
i would react to trending things that
also could splinter off into multiple
ideas
you're reacting to goth alt
tick tocks it could be very big i was
watching a
a guy follow reactive people freestyling
on tick tock
and i got he got my full watch time last
night on my smart tv
20 minutes or so and i was him reacting
to the tick tocks
um and so i would that's also
trend surfing is what we teach and so
reacting to trends commentating on
trends here's the key
your niche your subculture your
community is so clear
so anybody who's already subscribed
would probably be
interested or at least explore you
reacting to that kind of stuff
i would potentially dive into comedy
again
pick and choose you might say you see
channels that do like
every dad at disney and
and then the the the comedian will clip
together a vlog
of like things dads say at disney like
and i don't i can't think of anything i
haven't taken my son to disney yet and
i'm not
in that full dad mode but you get you
get the idea so it might
you understand here's the huge key you
understand your subculture
you understand this community so like
a video could go viral of like
self-awareness of 10 things 10 funny
things
goth people do you know and
and you give it a shot and here's the
power of the react
or more halls or more
you know cert it could be search based
it could be related to reviewing music
it could be related to reviewing a
specific product that's trending in your
community
so you basically have the full stack of
video ideas
types of videos that you could create
and the key is you're applying it
to a very specific niche and i'm super
glad you asked this question it came on
because
i think people make that mistake they
think well i'm like a goth fashion
channel
no i think you're cryptic jasmine which
is actually
a very good umbrella brand to answer
your question
that then allows you to experiment on a
lot of different things and to the point
of the interviews 100
and so you can interview friends or
other social media influencers or
whoever has been on here
first but then of course the interview
strategy is you always can shoot for the
moon with the interviews too
who are the um
there's a guy named russell who says
make your dream 50-100 list open up
a google excel or google sheets and
write down
50 and not to categorize celebrities or
influencers or anybody
but you know there's a list celebrities
there's be less celebrities there's c
break it all down come up with a hundred
names of people you'd love to interview
could be musicians artists hey everybody
watching good good thing to do
you don't have to have an interview show
to bring a guest on your channel
who's your dream 50 list who's your
dream 100 list and
reach out to all 100 especially too if a
lot of them are a
and b level influencers you reach out to
all 100
maybe one or two or three will say yes
and that's another video that could
bring
again key with all of this is then stage
two
you get some of the videos break out
some of the videos
lead to some exposure some of the videos
cause some growth and then stage three
is double down on what's working so you
get to go on a 12 to 24 month journey
of experimentation trying different
video formats
reaching out doing some different
interviews then
what gets measured gets improved you go
back review what's working
and um and then maybe shift and say
okay i'm going to phase out all these
styles the reacts didn't work
it wasn't really a thing for me or they
did i'm gonna phase out these
experiments and
really lean in to uh the videos that
have
evidence that are really helping my
channel grow resonating with people
listening the entire time to the
comments and listening to the data
comments are only one form of feedback
and sometimes
they can be harmful because you read one
comment
that you go oh i need to change my whole
you don't need to change your whole
strategy off one comment
if the like button is evidencing that
your community likes it
you're getting we get so i know you know
we upload a video and two people dislike
it and i know it like pops
our whole day it's like who the heck are
the two people that wait for me to
upload the video
but do the math if you vidiq shows it
really easy
if a video is getting even one of your
videos got 83 percent that's still what
like a b
plus a b one got 89 percent
and and vid iq shows that one as yellow
89 dude if i got 89 in high school my
parents would have been way happier than
they were
because i wasn't like that's really good
and of course you're getting in the 90s
so even if you're like wow
16 people dislike this if 88 people
liked it then just follow the math so
follow the math follow the views
follow the data listen to the comments
because in the comments
we'll give you feedback about what
people are resonating with but you
interpret all of it together and from
there
i would um scale your channel because i
think you're off to a great start
you're in a great niche and you have a
very clear brand creative name around it
you've got momentum um let me know what
you think
so helpful and i love the idea about 100
you know the list of 100 names and i'm
definitely going to do that and this
this is inspiring like just hearing you
say you're on like a right track
whoa that gave me a boost so thank you
so much i'm going to keep learning
and i love being part of this community
you're welcome
uh cryptic jasmine thanks so much for
coming on thank you
hey coffee with candle crew smash the
like button
if you're getting value and if even that
last breakdown gave you any value
today's episode is brought to you by
thinkmasterclass.com
if you want to go deeper on some of this
stuff and really come up with great
video ideas specifically learn three
reasons youtubers fail and how to avoid
those mistakes
how to grow your youtube channel this
year even if you're just starting out
and you don't have any on-camera
experience
and also the most recent tactics based
on youtube's recent updates
um you don't want to miss that web class
we just updated it to on demand
and so um sometimes i do it live
there's a replay for a while right now
for a limited time it's on demand
so you can watch it at any time
thinkmasterclass.com link in the
description down below if you want to
check out that free class
of course at the end of one hour of just
incredible strategic value
that you can apply right now i'll let
you let know a little bit more
about our community called video ranking
academy and uh
maybe that's something you're into maybe
not either way you got nothing to lose
checking out the master class and uh
hope to serve you and help you reach
your goals with youtube
in any way possible um in the future
we'll do future coffee with kennels cole
and sandy
and ivan and jesse uh i do have a
meeting i am
super late for and tony is uh super
gracious
as we are on the momentum of almost half
past the hour on the coffee with kennel
thank you everyone for coming on today
and being a part
good to see you teeny good to see you
brendan
sparks my man someday
someday let's collab uh hashtag vrafam
if you're in the chat today the question
of the day is what
product could you review or skill
could you teach on youtube we talked
about answer specific questions review
specific
products and teach specific skills
so drop that in the comments or in the
live chat any aha moments that you have
today
coffee with kennel water with kennel
on a wednesday
and uh anointed skin always good to see
you thanks so much for being here if
dee's near
say what up uh to him and uh
yeah appreciate y'all love y'all
michelle tech thanks for being here
appreciate y'all keep on grinding
rise and grind hey listen be great
remember that we're here to uh help you
reach your goals with youtube
and so keep punching fear in the face
keep punching perfectionism in the face
and never forget that you gotta
just press record i'm sean cannell this
has been coffee with kannel
see you next time